what's up believe nation is time for
another update on the path to 1 million
subscriber challenge that I'm on
basically I'm highlighting my journey to
get to 1 million subscribers and giving
you some tips advice and feedback along
the way to help you achieve whatever
your YouTube goals are so last month
when I did the video I had let me see I
had six hundred and thirty nine thousand
subscribers I'm sitting now at six
ninety eight so thirty thousand swing no
sixteen thousand swing this is awesome
swing in a positive direction it's
awesome getting closer to hit my million
goal the past couple videos I've talked
about the importance of upload frequency
I've talked about looking at people like
Eric Thomas and Gary Vaynerchuk people
who are considered to have immense
talent people whose channels I love and
it's produced some amazing content and
Eric wasn't producing enough content to
hit massive YouTube goals Gary now
started to increase its frequency and is
going to pass me soon and so again this
may not be the only thing YouTube is not
the only thing I understand these people
have other businesses and it's great I
do too this series is focused only on
how to get subscribers for your channel
and so we've talked a lot about upload
frequency it's really important for
YouTube it's part of their algorithm
they want you to upload regularly once a
day is the new minimum I met three per
day using my team there's a big growth
that you'll get from going once per week
to once per day another big jump from
once per day to two per day in terms of
how much YouTube will promote your stuff
between two and three not as big a gap
so may not be worth going to that
extreme but I'm testing that and playing
around with it so I encourage you
increase your upload frequency maintain
quality and you'll see a dramatic rise
in YouTube channel it doesn't mean that
you can't have success uploading fewer
videos but why drive on the side roads
when you can go on the highway right I'm
playing the YouTube's algorithm and if
you do it as well you'll be able to beat
people who have more skills who have
more money who have more of a background
in it because you understand your
algorithm better today I want to focus
on understanding which series are
working and which aren't and I'm going
to model and compare another youtubers
that's that we've had some fun with
Grant Cardone
of a channel he's been on my channel
talking about his book we've done some
videos on him a great guy I look at if
you're looking for anything about
entrepreneurship sales motivation he's a
good youtuber to check out and so I'm
going to compare my channel to his and
give him some recommendations to
increase his YouTube goals as well so
let's pull up the data quickly so you
can see here I'm at six hundred ninety
seven thousand subs grades at two
hundred and forty-eight what's
interesting as we scroll down you see
that grant subs being pretty much
consistent around the 200 range per day
until recently were really shut up and
he's actually coming close to me and
beating me on some days here
good job grant and one of the things I
want look at dissecting his channel is
are all the videos that he's doing
adding to the channel helping him out
with his growth and before jumping on
his I want to show you an example for
mine the two things that I really pay
attention to when I'm evaluating a new
series is watch time because watch time
is the single most important variable
that YouTube looks like if you are
giving YouTube watch time for their
videos they will reward your videos and
rank you higher so every news here is
that I want to look at the watch time
and then I look at is it leading to
subscriber growth or not for me if my
goal is to get two million subscribers
that's the name of this series the next
goal on my list then I need to make sure
that every series that I launched leads
to subscriber growth and so I'll usually
give a series three to four chances to
see if it's helping me with my
subscriber growth then I keep it if it's
not I'll kill it unless it serves
another purpose if I'm making a sales
video I'm showing my life if there's a
strategic reason behind the video b-side
subscriber growth then I keep it but if
there isn't if I'm hoping to use this
video to help me grow my channel and it
doesn't lead to subscriber growth that's
when we kill it so let's take a quick
look at two of the videos that I did and
then we'll jump into grants channel this
is the first video that I did on this
series how to get 1 million YouTube
subscribers this video had 10 days watch
time which isn't that great and only led
to eight subscriptions so it's not a
fantastic start for what a video would
get on my channel but it's worth an
extra shot and extra test the second one
I did was me and Gary Vaynerchuk that
was the last one in a series this one
has 40 days launch time and it drove 62
new subscribers which is better and so
this is Version three right now in the
series
this one right here is version three and
we'll see how well it does and this will
help tell me am I going to keep this
series or not and so I highly encourage
you to look at for every video series
that you launch whatever new ideas you
have give it three or four tests to get
some good data on and does it lead to
watch time and does it lead to
subscribers to your channel if it does
keep it if it doesn't kill it so let's
jump in on grants Channel and I can show
you what he's doing so this is grains
Channel and grant is doing an amazing
job as the content it's really rare to
find people who are keeping up with me
on the content I think actually recently
he's ahead of me this is two hours ago
17 hours 18 hours 18 hours 19 hours 22
hours one thing I would say if you're
going to post this much spread it out a
little bit more so if you're going to
post five six videos in a day spread
them out over a couple hours each times
but not back-to-back because it gives a
little bit of more room for the videos
to breathe so here 22 1918 18 17 these
are all going to be lumped together and
all of these videos could have had more
views if you space them out like this
one that was two hours ago
one day Tuesday and so on so it's great
to see Grant uploading tons of content
and I consider grant to be an amazing
speaker and has lots of great wisdom and
vice to share so what's the deal he's
uploading tons of content but in stuck
at 250,000 subs
let's break down some of the series so
we can look at where he's doing right
and what is doing wrong so this is a
typical video the new ones coming out at
least 46 days watch time it's awesome 18
subscriptions driven here's another one
150 days watched time 13 subscriptions
driven 27 days wise parents 12
subscriptions driven so he's driving
between 10 to 20 subscribers per new
video that he puts out that's the belt
grant so this is all kind of grant just
talking ranting into his phone doesn't
have to be a setup it's just she's just
going off the cop and grant is grants is
one of the best at doing this going off
the cuff being live sharing his opinion
and rolling with the punches and so a
typical great vide one who's just doing
that leads to 10 to 20 subs which is
great so next one I'll look at some of
his series so this is a series a house
called ask the pro grant does not
actually in these videos here and look
at the difference on the video so 5 days
watch time
zero subscriptions driven so the other
really important thing to understand
about YouTube's algorithm and this is
worth a pause on this point here if you
have a video that underperforms your
average if you have a video that does
really poorly on your channel it
actually hurts your future videos this
was an important lesson I learned so I
was just putting out tons of content
content of the content figured let
YouTube pick what's going to work it's
adding value to the audience I don't
care if it video only gets a thousand
views or 3,000 views doesn't really make
a difference it's just still high
quality content infant video does not do
well especially considering what your
average video will do then that video
hurts the future videos that come out on
your channel the flip side is if a video
does really well if it takes off then
that video will help your future videos
on your channel so you always want to be
producing content that is better than
the average it keeps raising the bar on
watch time for the channel but this is
really important because if you have a
series that is a zero subscribers growth
and is underperforming compared to your
average then the whatever future video
rank puts out that may be him ranting
even though those typically overperform
YouTube will not rank it as well because
this asked the pro video underperformed
so that's where it's really really
really important to pay attention to the
series that I work in and not and the
ones that aren't kill them because they
hurt all your future videos so let's
jump back in and look at the stream
again so this is asset pro and maybe
it's because grants not in this show
that it doesn't do as well this often
happens with personality driven channels
when it's you know under somebody's name
and then somebody comes on and you know
grants out there the video won't do as
well so this video has 0 subscribers
growth here's another one ask the pro
same guy has another guest coming on 11
needs watch negative one subscriptions
driven so he actually lost subscribers
because of this video he lost the
subscribers instead of it growing he's
losing base because of this and so maybe
there are other asset Pro videos I
haven't gone too far back in the series
maybe you know I just happened to pick
two that underperformed but in general
if a video series is lead is negative
ROK's
and is not doing well compared to your
usual videos on time watched then it's
time to
that series move on something else
unless it serves a strategic purpose to
help in your business your main business
how you make money how you add value
grow next I want to jump in on some of
grant shorter clips so what he'll often
do here is to have a mean big video like
this so this is a one of grants videos
cardones own talk mo saving for
retirement 72 days watched seven
subscriptions driven it's okay it's
actually it's interesting how his set
pieces like this underperform his life
stuff because this takes a lot of time
right there's set-up time this crew time
there's questions you know a lot of
effort that goes into making one of
these videos for it to only have seven
subscriptions given compared to
something like this it's 18 this is 13
like this took grant ten minutes is
sitting there on his phone he gets 157
days watch time in 13 subs driven
compared to this where there's a lot
more team and effort involved so finding
ways for grant to be more off-the-cuff
live exciting doing crazy things I think
would really help this channel but what
I really wanted to get into here was he
has this clip that comes out on May 21st
and each has this clip which comes out
also on May 21st which is just a short
version of something that he says in the
original video so this video is 38
minutes long this video is one minute
long look at this look at the difference
72 days watched two days watched seven
subs driven two subs driven and so this
video again is underperforming what's on
his channel YouTube doesn't like this
video they're going to down right in
case they're not going to send it out
it's not going to get a lot of attention
attraction awareness it's not going to
show up a lot on the recommended down
here on the side and now the future
video the grandpa tub right after this
is going to take a hit if you produce a
video that is below your average your
next video takes a hit and so it's super
important to understand he does it again
here here he's doing affiliate marketing
in Grant Cardone coaching awesome 52
days watch time amazing 23 subscriptions
driven great so it's leaving two new
subs finding him he puts out a
one-minute version of it again let's
check the dates May 21st
again May 21st same thing now spacing it
out may help a little bit because the
people just saw this they're not going
to want to watch this again and they're
not going to be moved by because I just
heard the same
point so spacing that up can really help
but still I'd be inclined to kill this
series look at this 46 hours of watch
time 52 days of watch time compared to
46 hours of watch time YouTube hates
this video will not promote it will not
give it more exposure and then again
whatever video grande puts out next is
going to take a hit because he put this
video up but the four subs so it's okay
but this is the one to pay attention to
and this one-minute series should I
would test it putting it later on so
instead of putting the same day put it
next week where people who may not have
seen the original video can see this
short bit or just test to see if it's
working because maybe that short
one-minute clip should only be on
Instagram or only on Facebook and not on
YouTube because I don't want you taking
the hit here's another quick example 36
hours of watch time and one subscription
driven for one minute 32 video this is
something that the team should be paying
attention to insane stop making these
videos save them for social the other
channels and put up the better stuff on
YouTube so the next thing we want to do
is go series by series and pay attention
to what is putting up and you do this on
your channel look at every series that
you have it's harder when you're looking
at it from an outsider's perspective if
I have access to grant analytics I could
provide a much more in-depth report
because you can create groups a lot more
easily but go series by series so here's
one confessions of an entrepreneur with
brand code own he's having a guest come
on 67 days watch time great drove 11
subs that's about average with his grant
rant series with his phone so again like
is it worth this spending the time to
book this person to do all the work to
drive what son maybe he gets a lot of
you know fight with it maybe he loves it
maybe that's where he gets his mojo from
and so that may be a series worth
continuing but again compared to
something like this or something like
this where he's just sitting there with
his phone a kids way better results so
just something to think about when
you're comparing how much time it takes
to make a video
here's another series so 91 days watch
time on young hustlers 8 subs driven
decent watch time okay for subs again I
don't know how much grant is in here he
is so he joins later on this is another
one I will look at like boom okay watch
time is DISA on this one subs are below
average what I what grant should be
getting I go back and look at every
Hustler's episode and do an analysis of
is this series we're keeping what topics
really hit what topics didn't so they
make the young hustler series even
better here's another one Cardone
mastermind events live at two o'clock
this is a half an hour mastermind call
with somebody not grant you know so type
an hour of this guy answering questions
in ten days watch time not that great
negative two subs so he lost subscribers
because of this video and again the next
video grant puts up is going to take a
hit because this video underperform next
i want to talk about some of his more
high-profile guests and this is where
grant has really started to excel
recently if I go back to his social
blade account you can see that he was
recently really taking off a lot of that
is because of the guest that he's had on
board so this is a video where he
brought on Gary Vaynerchuk it's
relatively new 476 days of watch time
and a hundred and eighty subscriptions
driven so still a new video still gonna
do well so going to continue to drive
traffic and awareness for him so you
know they mentioned this video that he
spent a lot of time trying to get Gary B
to come on board and recruiting him and
back and forth and so it was worth it
and grant does a really good job
interviews he's really good in the live
setting here the next one he did here
Tai Lopez this one this is one of my
favorite Thai Lopez interviews of all
time and grant did a really good job I
really appreciated the hustle and the
drive and the questions here look at
that two years of watch time one of his
best videos of recent memory at least to
be two years of watch time and 203 three
subscriptions driven so this series
power players is working when he brings
on high-profile guests and you allow
grant to be grant and share his wisdom
ask the questions be real Ron the things
that grant does it works it helps
generate a lot of traffic attention
awareness this video goes up YouTube is
going to love whatever next video he
puts up but give him extra awareness so
I would definitely go hard on the power
player series and bring on more guests
too like grant the grant interview and
involve the audience next let's jump to
the genie show so I'm just basically
doing a sort of all the series that I
could find just quickly looking at his
channel on the video
upload so how to give back to genie show
30 90s watched okay two subscriptions
driven not great on a subscription
driven there's another example here the
genie show the business of marriage 39
days watch negative two subscriptions
driven so he's losing subscribers
because of the show and again it's going
to hurt him for the future videos
where this helps is it's long so you get
the watch time because it's a 48 minute
episode encourages other stuff which is
shorter so it's going to help with the
watch time but hurt him on the sub so
again I would go back and look at every
GE show just like young hustlers and say
hmm I'm getting decent watch time on it
but I'm not getting the subs that I
should be getting compared to my other
videos what's wrong do we cancel the
show do we find what episodes are
pulling really well and go more in on
that and again maybe some of these shows
have a strategic purpose so that it's
outside of just generating subs for his
channel maybe he really loves working
with his wife maybe really loves working
with his associate on the young hustlers
show and we've been there's other
reasons beyond just subscriber growth
but paying attention to it is important
the next thing I want to highlight are
the sales videos and this is something
that will often come up you know we want
to use our YouTube channel as an
opportunity to sell stuff to grow to
promote stuff and so grant was promoting
the 10x grow con and had all these
people kind of talking about how great
it was and again only four hours watch
this might be one of them the worst
videos of recent memory on grants
channel he lost a subscriber because of
it only had four hours watched time and
he had a bunch of these so he could go
to his channel around the time of this
conference there's maybe 15 of these
different videos of people just talking
about how great the 10x growth con was
and that hurt his channel but does the
reason for right is trying to promote
his conference a 10x pro/con and it's
okay to use your channel to promote
something that helps your business
objectives and so yes he's he's
knowingly taking a hit on his YouTube
growth losing a subscriber because of
this one hurting his future videos
because of the poor watch time but it's
helping him generate sales and awareness
and attention for his goal conference so
it's okay to have some videos that hurt
the channel is it leads to another
strategically important decision for
your company so here's another quick one
again negative one you lost discovered
of it only 10 hours watch time this
whole series of videos is going to hurt
the channel now we put out some great
quality content afterwards you start to
raise the average sir to get more
promotion awareness as well but I love
getting that momentum positive video
growth the last thing I want to talk
about is Grant's live stuff so this is a
recent one that grant did grant
interviews a job candidate live footage
so 141 days watch time 32 subs driven
this is a good video and it's just grant
sitting there talking to a guy who's
doing a job interview the camera shaking
his hand held is not a lot of production
quality kind of thinking that went into
it just grant doing his thing which
grant is amazing that if we go back to
another video on this channel this is
the recent one also from May 86 thousand
views five hundred and eleven days of
watch time and 221 subs driven so again
this is just a guy in a Thai Potter just
holding a camera
singing grant do his thing live right if
I go back this is from May 21st let's
find some other May 21st videos so this
one which which did well this is grant
ranting with just him in a camera right
May 21st also but only 13 subscriptions
driven May 21st
this one is May 21st 0 subs only five
days right May 21st minus one subs 11
days
fast-forward May 21st 39 days two subs
for the genie show me 19 4 hours minus
one subs the growth time we looked at
and then here 32 subs driven 141 days of
watch time on May 21st
just following grants around 500 11 days
to 21 subscribe and same day May 21st
just following grants around like grant
should if his only goal was I want to
get watch time I want to get views I
want to drive my YouTube channel to the
moon then he should just do a vlog and
have people follow him around and watch
him do his stuff live because that way
that's what he is amazing at if we go to
his channel look at all the videos that
he has the most popular video of all
time that he has is this doing an actual
live sales call sales training four
years ago one point four million views
let's check out the stats on this video
this it drove eight thousand three
hundred and thirty nine subscribers to
his channel this is the kind of stuff
that grant need to do more on so if I
was in charge of grants Channel if I was
in charge of advising him on his YouTube
strategy that's what I would focus on
I'd say less set pieces I'd say less
short one minute clips immediately after
a full-length clip I'd say going harder
on the videos where you can bring on
guests and have a great time with them
and do more live stuff of following you
around not to set up not the official
camera crew you like people following
you around doing something that Grant
Cardone does I think that's where you're
going to get the highest leverage from
your channel so that's my quick take on
Grant Cardone channel I'm a big fan of
the hustle and the upload frequency is
doing a great job on that and it's that
first channel exploding makes a couple
of minor tweaks that will really help
let me get into some questions you guys
had from last month's video and see what
you have that I can maybe help you out
with all right first up dude what two
one two there is no guarantee that
YouTube will exist 60 years from now let
alone forever
who cares about 60 years from now uh how
old am I I just turned 37 I'm gonna be
97 in 60 years who cares what's happened
in 60 years I care about what's
happening right now
that's what it's all about I'm not
addicted to YouTube I want to have a
billion entrepreneurs and wherever the
entrepreneurs are that's where I want to
be I never wanted to be YouTube famous
and my initial goal starting this wasn't
I have a million subscribers it's the
house of billion entrepreneurs however
that happened and so if YouTube in two
years is populating or and everybody's
moving to Instagram or snapchat or
whatever the newest thing is that
everybody's on then that's where I'm
going to be and that's where you should
be to don't hold onto the platforms like
MySpace and all the other ones that go
under you could have made a serious
amount of money had a serious amount of
impact on myspace in the day but if you
stick there then you're not going to be
successful so you have to be where the
attention is if your customers are there
where your audience is you need to be
that's marketing 101 be where your
customers are so right now that's
YouTube this video will help people who
are trying to get whatever the YouTube
goal is your subscription goals are pay
10
into the series upload frequently do the
data to understand that this series is
working this one isn't you'll have
success next starlight create 1 million
Google account subscribe your desired
channel and tada that is a way to get
youtube subscribers to get to a million
you can also buy them if you want this
is talking about legit ways though to
get to 1 million subscribers I don't buy
my subs next Ryan watch out for value
tainment see has quality content I'm a
fan I'm a fan of Patrick B David it's
got some great content for entrepreneurs
maybe I'll do a breakdown of his channel
at some point Patrick's been on my
channel I've been on his it's a great
collaboration and I'm supporting anybody
who wants F entrepreneurs I don't think
there's enough quality people who are
trying to help entrepreneurs on YouTube
so it's been amazing to see the work
that Patrick's put out and I would love
for him to hit a million subs as well
that means that entrepreneurs are being
helped next RC sparks to do YouTube is
going to pummel you guys because your
views are small you're taking lots of
YouTube real estate producing no views
subs mean nothing to YouTube if they're
not watching your films watch time grow
watch time yes I agree dude that's why
we're talking about watch time it's not
just about self but it's definitely not
about views don't pay attention to views
at all you're looking at the wrong
metric do i generate 42 million minutes
in watch time per month which for a
channel of my size sub wise that's
really good I'm hitting above my belt
views don't matter watch time does so in
this entire series of how do we break
down what a good series looks like right
it's watch time and subs driven that's
how I analyze if the series is good or
not and that's how you should do what
we're said by there are suspect value
teams will be catching you guys soon so
a lot of love of Patrick in this series
I'm a fan and I look forward to doing
breakdown utopia I don't agree with your
strategy Evan there are tens of channels
1 million subs and almost none of them
have 3,800 videos as you have you can -
ty - king of YouTube has less videos
than you but almost 55 million subs so
what it's not my strategy it's what
YouTube wants you can win so first of
all PewDiePie started at an earlier time
what they cared about most was views so
there's different algorithm but
PewDiePie could win even harder people
do some more content right look at
cutie pies Channel recent look at how
many times he's complained about the
YouTube algorithm he's complaining
instead of adjusting and so while he
still may be number one and he still
produces content at his channel and his
audience enjoys he's fighting the
YouTube algorithm instead of going with
it
and what I'm saying is you could do that
you can still have success it's just not
efficient if you can produce quality
content and play to the algorithm that
you're dealing with you're just going to
win harder could you point to be winning
much harder instead of complaining about
the algorithm so you'd be having a lot
more success so sure you don't need to
have 3800 videos there's a lot of people
we get there a lot faster than me but if
you're producing quality content and
you're producing it more regularly you
will win harder period next up VCG
construction as a new creator do you
think going live could help us get
viewers to archana live is a strange
thing live has its own algorithm I used
to go live all the time I used to have 5
to 8 live things a week usually all the
Thursday kind of condensed back to back
this is where I had to cut a lot of the
live stuff out of my channel because it
was a video series that attracted a lot
of attention immediately right so if
you're online and you live people will
come and fled to your channel but it was
causing negative subscriber growth so a
lot of people had on for the live
interviews they didn't pull as well
people to nobody they were maybe they
didn't like their advice and so because
of that I lost subscribers it's not
significant not like losing hundreds of
subs each time but I don't want to put
the effort into making a video and
having guests on and booking them and
then it leading to my channel getting
smaller right that's a problem unless
again that person serves a strategic
reason right we have a relationship it's
leading to something else outside of
business I just want to do good by them
whatever it is is a reason that I know
I'm going to hurt my channel form and so
if you do live videos and they don't do
extremely well then it's going to hurt
your channel and so a lot of people
aren't great at going live and so I
really think about it I would try it and
see but again if after 3 to 4 episodes
you're finding that it's not leading to
subscriber growth and it's hurting your
channel then I would cut it or work on
getting better right there's a lot of
series on my channel that I could cut
but I want to work on getting better
it's part of my growth and so I'm okay
holding back the growth of my channel on
some series for my own personal
development so there's a strategic
reason for doing it that's all
Alexander I personally get more value
from your channel heaven Gary's channel
has become much more fancy like an
action movie it looks like a TV series
about an entrepreneur yours has less
Drive and motion but it turns of
practice info and value much better I
know the thumbnail has like me against
Gary or me against Grant it's not meant
to say that my channel is any better or
worse right you'll get different things
from Gary because everything's been
great get different things for me as
often we all serve our own niche I'm a
fan of what Gary does I watch pretty
much all of his episodes I love the
support the idea here is in to bash Gary
or bash Grant is to look at what they're
doing on YouTube compare it to what I'm
doing for me to learn and also for me to
give you guys lessons to help you in
your growth or for YouTube but I don't
want to get into like whose channel is
better it's a lot of love for Patrick
big David to in the chat I love it but I
don't want to get into whose channel is
better and why it's not the point of
this I want to help you build your
channel and build your business next up
is Explorer list just stumbled across
your channel and watch his video with
interest you're obviously focus your
energy on building a large number of
subscribers but should not be on the
number of views you're getting I'm not a
Gary Vee fanboy but his video views
appear to be considerably higher and I
was wondering why you were focusing on
number of subscribers compared with
getting more views on your videos so I'm
talking about this a little bit and
again me versus Gary it's not something
I really want to get into but our
strategies are tactics super interested
because I maybe I can learn something as
well looking at Gary Stefan he saw his
big growth when he went from one video a
day to two a day even from like one or
two a week to once a day to two a day
that's where you start seeing the
massive growth that's why he's catching
up and going to pass me on YouTube for
subscribers if I'm looking at the
metrics though I don't care about views
we talked about this already when I'm
looking at how to evaluate a series you
look at watch time and you look at
description driven the difference
between my content and Gary's content a
lot of Gary's stuff hits with fire
immediately and then fades most of his
daily vlog content whether you're a fan
but some people don't like the axe
motion some people love it and they get
inspired and that's what motivates them
to want to do more work whether you like
it or not if you're following somebody's
vlog typically it's a rabid fan base who
watch every episode but they don't go
back Gary Vee episode you know 30
whatever his vlog was most people aren't
going to be watching that
so you'll see huge spikes so you get
lots of views and then it crashes where
a lot of my videos are geared for
long-term consumption and so the initial
views don't necessarily take off my
videos are also a lot longer typically
than what Gary's putting out and so my
watch time versus Gary's I would put us
I would put us up against it I'd love to
see what here is watch time is I would
say that I get more watch time than Gary
I think I get more views than Gary let's
check it in you know let's check it out
right now it's going to possibly glide
so this is a cool cool here you have the
option to compare modeling the masters
it's me gary vay-ner-chuk let's compare
so tubs I'm still ahead but he's closing
the gap he's getting there I'm red right
he's getting there he's what twenty
thousand subs behind at the moment he's
getting there let's see what her suitor
so sub per day look at that he's had one
crazy day where he grew we're still kind
of close but net he's beating me a
little bit it's close views I don't know
what happened there so we have averages
so I get one hundred and eighty nine
thousand daily views he gets one hundred
and forty five thousand yearly views one
thousand one hundred daily subs so I'm
so I'm ahead of Gary on daily views so
some surprises you're looking at uses a
metric but you're only looking at
short-term immediate views when a video
launches where a lot of my stuff takes
time to build up I both evergreen
content I think is relevant and valuable
forever and a lot of Gary stuff is super
timely so it's not right or wrong
everybody has their approach and Gary as
a set is passed me on subscribers but
I'm ahead of him on views Wesley love
this series can't wait for the next
month's episode thank you for the love
Wesley hey to somebody you want me to
compare my channel to and and again it's
the comparison is
to say who's better than who is to look
at what that other person is doing give
some recommendations and advice and to
that process you guys can learn as well
to help build your channel so the
something we're going to do next the
breakdown comparison let me know in the
comments and I might just do it
next up block conservative media thank
you for this video there's an intro help
with your YouTube page also what
inspired you to start your page Thanks
this goes against what most people say
the YouTube experts
an intro video does very little for your
channel I'm not a fan of having intro
videos I think the best thing that you
can do and you can test it test it one
day against another a lot of people put
a lot of effort into make an intro video
first off most people don't go to your
homepage and and watch a video there but
even the ones that do what I want to hit
them with is the video that will lead to
the most subscriber growth and so I
think and I've tested having a video at
the front so you can go on your
analytics and look at all the videos
that you have look at what video leads
to the most subscriber growth so for me
it's one of my top 10 between Steve Jobs
and Tony Robbins or one of the one of
the top ten I'll put that video as the
one that I want to put because it leads
to the most subscriber growth the whole
idea of you need to tell the person tell
the audience how many videos are going
to put and what your schedule is like
and all this stuff people don't care I
can tell you what my schedule is most
people don't care most people don't
remember
most people don't plan their schedule
according to one youtubers schedule
maybe one that you just really
absolutely love in your heart chords i
die-hard fan of but for the most part
people don't care what the schedule is
so don't tell them just make awesome
stuff as often as you can and the intro
video on your channel should not be
welcome video it should be the video
that converts the highest if your goal
is you to subscribers the video that is
on the homepage of your channel should
be the one that converts the highest and
you know what that is but you're looking
at your analytics I think it's the best
way to go
next up Sohail hi Evan I thought I don't
think it's a YouTube algorithm that has
anything to do with number of
subscribers algorithm can directly help
your videos to be ranked higher in
search but only indirectly can help with
number of subscribers just by making
more people to watch your
videos and therefore get interested in
at least one and then subscribe that is
mostly true and so I'm talking about to
the whole point of the algorithm is to
get your video showing up to get your
video being recommended to people your
subscribers and nonsubscribers so that
you get watch time so you get attention
you get use you get come to get
engagement if your video shows up you're
going to get more subscribers that's a
YouTube album that we're talking about
now the part that you're missing that I
haven't really talked about either in
this series is there's a thing called
view velocity and so when you first put
out a video on your channel that's not a
live video you just launch a video how
quickly that video gets watch time is
really really really important if the
video starts getting watch time really
quickly YouTube will promote it more if
it's not getting a watch time very
quickly then it's going to promote it
less and so that's why your subscribers
can really help you because if you have
a big subscriber base and they watched a
new video that you put up really quickly
it'll help the view lacet II which helps
us rank in the algorithm which will help
new people find your videos as well so
see you next up is Nick great video I'm
taking this message to heart I recent
launch my youtube channel for therapy
and I'm uploading approximately five
videos a week I love that my goal is to
post daily as a brand new channel my
question is how do you deal with not
getting views should I not even look at
the numbers and just keep posting on a
consistent basis I want to make sure I'm
not missing anything thank you in
advance Nick so Nick when you're first
starting out you can't get super
attached to it you also don't have
enough data to really make important
decisions when I'm breaking down grants
videos there's enough data to work with
he has two hundred something thousand
subscribers he's making consistent
content he's done a lot of videos in a
series so we can see okay here's how
much an average grant video will do
here's how much this series is doing you
can see is a better or worse it's again
worth continuing this series or not if a
video has grants in it it does better
for gritos doesn't have grant in it it
doesn't do as well if grants is allowed
to be live and crazy and do this thing
it does better if it's stage and perform
and structured it doesn't do as well
right so you can start to outline trends
and has enough data to make a decision
when you're first getting started you
don't have enough data to make a
decision and so all I would focus on
now it's just getting better listen at
the start of a YouTube channel you're
going to suck anyway your videos not
going to be great you may be a great
therapist you may know your crap inside
out it doesn't mean you're great on
camera it doesn't mean you're great at
making videos doesn't mean your editing
is amazing you know I'm sure there's a
lot of repetition I'm sure there's some
nervousness still coming out there's a
lot that could be better and so I would
focus in the early days more on just
making better videos I'm a firm believer
that the quantity leads to the quality
and now is the time to experiment to try
to hone your skills to improve and not
get so attached to how many views one
video gets or how many comments one way
to get the start of my thing my channel
wasn't getting any comments zero so in
fact you have one or two comments coming
in on a video if that happens that's
that's amazing but one video may spike
for the wrong reason right maybe you put
some keyword in there and that takes off
and you think you did a great job but
you didn't you know really right now I
would not pay attention to the numbers
if you're only doing this to get numbers
then you're in it for the wrong reasons
focus on building your skills honing
your craft and get better otherwise the
numbers are going to keep pulling you
down man you look at that every day
you're going to be going on you're going
to be depressed next up is sue I love
that you say we have to get better we
not the camera not the lighting I could
okay I will be honest I've spent hours
researching lights and so on when I
realize that this is just a very natural
way of resisting moving forward because
I'm just scared so that's some amazing
self-awareness listen we all want
shortcuts we all want shortcut to the
last question you know about Nick like
he wants a grouse channel to it we want
shortcuts and so if you think it's easy
to go and buy lights right it easy to
spend whatever it is $10 $30 couple
hundred dollars on some lights it's easy
to think if I get a better camera then
things will be better but the end of the
day if you're making this kind of video
a talking head video you're an expert
you know sue I don't know what you're
you're doing is your negotiation angels
so if you're a negotiator you're making
expert quality content look at grand
stuff
grant has budget grant has a team right
there's people behind those professional
cameras there's
right that he's invested into building
up a set there's structure he's paying
people to do this with him and his best
stuff is grant on a phone going on a
rant or showing something or somebody
following grants around with the you
know jerky camera while he's explaining
something or doing something in a job
interview or in the sales call right
that's his best stuff because grant has
talent grant has skills and so if you
have the skills at what you do then you
can rise to go to the top and so it's
really important that you focus on that
it's hard work you have to make a lot of
videos you got to practice like anything
else you know if you're in the go shader
you didn't just come out of the womb as
a great negotiator right you had to
practice you have to improve you had to
learn you had the Train apply that same
approach it's slow it's frustrating is
painful it sucks I would love to say buy
this one hundred dollar lights and
you're set and your videos will all be
amazing forever but that's not the
shortcut and if you understand that if
you work on your craft and get better at
it daily and you keep working on it your
videos will get better
who dhoka please comment on how someone
who works in other job or is run in a
business can fit a decent you can
following into the schedule it takes me
half a day to record a short video and
the three hours to edit it even with the
simplest edits I don't have time to
produce videos to post multiple times a
week and edit them down and all that is
there any hope should I even bother
until I'm able to spend more time on
this you just practice when I meet my
first videos it took me more than a day
to make up just me talking head like me
with a camera that's it because I made
mistakes because I was nervous because I
was scared because I sucked I wanted to
do it again and I was trying to memorize
a script and I forgot it's going to take
take and take and take and take right
so hundreds of times to do one video and
now when I get to the studio where
record 60 videos 70 videos in a day the
more you practice something the better
you're going to get so depending on what
it is that you're doing it won't take
you half a day as you get better at it
to film the video I mean I'll take you
three hours to edit something as you get
better at it so practice practice so you
can get that half a day video down to 30
minutes get better
and as you build up you can strip the
bucket okay if I don't want to you know
my best talents are in front of the
camera I need to get an editor that's
what helped me move from a video week to
video a day is I got an editor you can
get part-time people full-time people
you don't need to go full time at the
start though I love up work so website
to find people around the world who can
who are talented who have a passion for
what you're doing who want to work from
home and I have two and a half full-time
editors on up work and I send the files
by Dropbox in that's how I do it so if
this is your dream don't give up and
it's frustrating it's slow because you
know what a good video looks like and
you know that your your quantity needs
to be better but like anything else at
the start of anything else expect the
suck at the beginning if you're going to
learn Taekwondo you can look at
Taekwondo masters and say these guys are
great just because they're great doesn't
mean that you need to quit just practice
get better you'll pick up the moves
faster and then as you grow you can
surround yourself with a team to help
you pick up the pace even more Piercy
one one one yeah but Gary had someone
else film and edit all his videos this
is why he can post for more a day also
songs videos are only one or two minutes
long which are just cuts from some of
the longer videos sure gary has an
advantage I have an advantage I have I
have people on my team about eight
people on my YouTube team that allows
you to post three times a day so you
can't get the three times a day or even
once a day right away but plan for it
that's where you need to get to that's
the standard right now that's where you
want to be if you want to win with the
YouTube algorithm so you're not there
yet just like anything else right if you
want to get that car you want to have
those savings you want to have this
level of customer growth you want to
develop this website create this product
whatever it is you have a goal work
towards it you start where you are with
what you have that's every successful
person story if all you look at is
someone who like Gary or me who has
seven hundred thousand subscribers and
think that you can compete at that level
right now you're going to be depressed
you can't compare your start to somebody
else's middle look at how we started and
you'll see you'll see the growth and
that's what you need to do for yourself
the one or two minute clips they don't
always work look at grains Channel right
we did a breakdown the one or two minute
clips of his channel are hurting his
channel he's getting some subscriber
growth from it but it's getting not
great watch time and if he keeps doing
it's going to hurt his future videos
that are coming up so it's not that it's
a great strategy to do next up professor
Nez I like your point Evan but I
actually felt Gary was overkill when he
accelerated his uploads
I actually unsubscribe to him it was
overbearing should there be some kind of
balance don't you think quality affects
the quality and that your audience will
be fatigued by upload overload Thank You
professor Nez
I hear you men some people will not
subscribe but he's winning the data
shows otherwise for every you Hussein I
don't like that I don't I don't listen
I'm not a huge fan of the daily beast
series I much prefer his askgaryvee show
I learned a lot more from that I don't
need to see Gary hustling for me to want
a hustle harder I don't get as much
education from The Daily Beast I'm not
I'm not as big a fan of that as aim of
the show I did not subscribe to him and
you did but he's winning people love
that stuff for every one of you there's
ten people who want more of the stuff so
you have to pay attention to the series
this entire video that I broke down
grant stuff the same thing he's posting
a lot of content and it could pay
attention to the series and what's doing
well and what's not and cut cut out the
weak ones and replace it with better
ones he's going to win even harder and
so I hear you but there's always room
for quality and I think you should
cannibalize yourself first don't let
somebody else take your audience away
cannibalize yourself so if you can
produce quality stuff go and do it some
people you will lose some people will
complain I'm sure some people
complaining on Gary's channel that he
was producing too much people have
unsubscribed for me for producing too
much content and the stuff I was making
wasn't hitting them enough it wasn't
good enough
I didn't provide them enough value for
them to want to stick around maybe they
came for one series and now that's only
a third of the videos that I put out
they don't like my other stuff and so
make sense again subscribe but net I'm
winning I'm getting more
so just pay attention to your data
Gary's data show that he's winning
so it's sad to lose someone like you but
it's worth it Karl Simmons I'm not sure
if you mentioned it before and I'm
watching a youtube series at some point
but how large is your team
so I eight people on my team mix of
editing researching got a guy comes in
and films me it doesn't really matter
like how big my team is now what gear I
use now it doesn't matter start with
what you have you can have think about
what you're great at if you're looking
at building a team what are you amazing
that what's the best thing that you want
to focus most of your time at and then
bring people on who can help support
that the first hire for me was a
part-time editor it allowed me to go
from one video a week to one a day but
from a part-time editor because it took
me so long editing and I want to be an
editor I had no ambition to get better
at it I didn't want to learn the skills
to improve myself at it I wanted to be
in front of the camera and so hire an
editor help me improve and that was let
me do one video a day was me and an
editor it's great context I guess to
understand where the people are at but
if you're just comparing yourself it's a
challenge right like I said before to
compare your beginning somebody else's
middle you're going to lose next up is
Nick great slap Evan value value value
and respond to Andy's comment if
animations are amazing and also add
massive amounts of value there are
channels like Kurt's go socked in a
nutshell that upload once a month they
only have 59 videos but have over three
million subs so content like that would
be a great fit for him if you have the
ability and time to compete for the rest
of us would definitely need to upload
more no this guy needs to upload more
once a month is not enough more you can
do it find a way create more okay let's
compare let's see let's find under
shimmered screen I never heard of it
Kurt sagat's in a nutshell here we go
let's compare so this guy is 4 million
subscribers I have 698 so he's crushing
me on the subscribers he started later
than I did as well I'm half his daily
subs almost and more than half his daily
views yeah I've got one hundred and nine
hundred eighty nine thousand daily views
he's at three hundred and twenty-nine
and you've got four million subscribers
to my 700,000 this is what happens we
don't promote enough content he's
winning but he could win harder if he
produce more content he's losing a
YouTube algorithm game and that may not
be what he want to do but he's going on
the slow streets he's riding a horse and
buggy that's what he's doing where I
want him to ride a Ferrari by doing more
he's fighting against the youtuber Govan
is winning because this content is so
good I happen to checked it out but to
get four million subscribers you're
doing something right but it could be
winning harder if you had better
strategies so do more do more come on
Kurtz Kurtz good sagged you got to do
more you can and part of that is for me
I believe if you have the ability to
change the world you have the ability to
help them you have the responsibility to
do as well a lot of the people with I
just came back from claimer Khan a lot
of people with bigger channels they're
doing ok but they could be doing more
they can be having a bigger impact they
could be making a bigger reach they're
not working as hot as it could and their
stuff means something to people
so thieves the ability to change the
world you did Billy to have an impact on
people's lives and you have the
responsibility to do more and so he's
going to this guy's going to get crushed
by somebody who understands the YouTube
algorithm better and produces inferior
quality content that upsets me next up
is Leo cheers Evan I learned a good
lesson but I must add neither Gary can
be you nor you can be him and the game
is to beat yourself this game 100% 100%
your goal to be the best version of you
but you can learn from other people to
help become the best version of you and
especially learn from their strategies
the fastest way to get somewhere it's a
look at who's already gone there and
learn from them so if you want to have
YouTube success go look at the people
who've had YouTube success and model
them tell you get there faster and
that's the point of the series I'm
trying to share with you guys so
strategy that I've use to help me as
well as learning from other people and
giving advice and what I would do
differently
or why they're winning so much Nikolai
Master Evan I think one of the reasons
why the live streams don't get as much
as the replays are the topics to be
covered notifications alerts reminders
when the live stream starts and probably
timing on YouTube's heavy viewership
traffic it's a different algorithm the
reasons why live streams don't do as
well as it's a different algorithm what
YouTube does is they promote a live
stream really heavily when it first
comes out it'll show up on the
right-hand side for the for the
suggested videos related videos it'll
it'll send notification the people who
signed up to be a subscriber on your
channel you can there's options in the
backend to have a feature when you go
live across all your videos and that
will help drive a lot of people
immediately to your video but once it's
done once it's finished YouTube doesn't
promote it as well as the other videos
they just don't it's a different
algorithm that's why it sucks because I
love doing live stuff but unless you
have really really good guess it's going
to hurt your channel relaxing sleep
station what do you think about reducing
your quantity to focus more on the
quality of the videos both to both
quantity plus quality the quantity leads
to the quality doing more quantity
improves your skills to get better for
the quality at the end of days quality
of look that's what's going to matter if
you produce a hundred videos a day and
they're all crap nobody's going to watch
or subscribe or comment or share you get
zero watch time you need good stuff but
more good stuff and I want you to win
the YouTube algorithm and produce more
high quality stuff do both get better
move faster practice practice practice
young Caesar Evan you're winning you
approach as calmly and firm into the to
hyper and I came across Geary to hyper
your common welcome and keep it up
there's lots of people who who love the
hyper and would much rather watch Garry
than me it's okay
you got to go all-in on you again our
styles are not what's in question I'm
looking at the tactics that he's used on
his channel to pull out things that you
could learn from and maybe me too
next up sukham hey Evan my first time
ever comment on your channel and I'm
loving the message in value brain that's
awesome and welcome aboard I actually
started blogging a week ago and put out
content once a day to a challenge the
last few years I posted two videos a day
and I'm seeing more people are checking
up
channel and more engagement thanks to
the tips and keep up the great work
first of all I love it why am i I'm
shaking my head is the amount of people
who will look at and who are commenting
that this strategy doesn't work but then
actually don't go and try it like just
try it here's a guy who's vlogging and
you go to a day and it's getting more
results it's not a strategy it just
works
it's what YouTube wants right now it's
their algorithm it works so do it or if
you can't do it you know that you're not
playing to the algorithm and you made
that strategic decision for whatever
reason but it's not this is my opinion
the people who are commenting that this
is you know your opinion and it doesn't
work just try it before saying that
something doesn't work you have to try
it and actually see so circum
first of all Congrats on the new vlog
it's awesome and it's great that you
tried it and it's great that you're
getting results alright there's a lot
more comments but I think I'm going to
end it there that was a lot of QA more
than I expected but I had fun doing it
so guys thank you so much for watching
let me know what questions you have to
help you build your YouTube channel you
have a question for me leave it down the
comments below I'll try to answer it
next time I did a lot of Q&A this time
so hopefully we'll get some more next
time remember you need lots of videos
the quantity leads to the quality but
you need lots of quality videos to win
it YouTube's algorithm game now and pay
attention to the series pay attention to
which videos are doing well
pay attention to the watch time create
stitches and subscribers gained and lost
and kill the series that are not doing
well replace them with new ones test try
and see what works that's going to help
you really build your channel up until
next month remember I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you soon